[Music]
it's great to be here uh i feel like
this is a good time to have a
declarative statement like it's great to
be here i find those are really fun if
you ever want to freak out your friends
though like here's a good one if you're
ever like watching just like a regular
night like it's a thursday you're
watching some netflix with some friends
just freak them out and look at them
during like a pause and be like
this is the best night of my life
just like a regular instantly freaks
everybody you know out there's actually
a better one though if you're hanging
out with people that you've only hung
out with like once or twice before let's
say you're in line for the lego movie
or whatever movie you happen to like in
this analogy so you turn to your friends
wait for a pause and turn to them and go
you guys are my real family
[Applause]
that'll instantly freak everybody you
know
i was reminiscing in my uh office
earlier today you know what i was
thinking about i was remembering how
great lying used to be remember lying
yeah the monologue's about lying
lying at one time was a wonderful thing
i'm not talking about like crazy hurting
people lies like yeah sure
i checked the bolts on the ferris wheel
not like that that's a bad lie i'm
talking about little lies simple stuff
like you invite me to do something i
don't want to do it but i also don't
want to hurt your feelings
enter the line you're just like uh my
dog's sick or i'll be out of town or i'm
sick and my dog will be out of town
who cares that little lie got me out of
apple picking with steve
your 6 a.m apple picking plans are [__]
steve
get them out of my face
steam
thank you lie now now i don't lie every
day i don't even lie every week i lie
maybe every four months it's a seasonal
treat
like a cadbury cream egg
but it's filled with like an easy way
out instead of a disgusting sugar yolk
you know what i mean
but then you know what ruined everything
the internet the internet ruined
everything
what am i
amish bad internet things were better
when we got our news from the corn
had high hopes for that one
for the picture of an amishman picking
up a piece of corn like what's that you
say
rain on friday
crowd sat it out that's okay i respect
that
i'm saying specifically not just the
internet but social media has ruined
lying lying's done because now everybody
knows what you're doing like people can
be like hey
i thought you said you were out of town
but yesterday i saw a vine of you and
your dog yucking it up in the park
thanks a lot vine lifelong friendship
destroyed because i just had to post a
six-second video of my dog sniffing so
many balls
just
all of the balls
thanks vine
but it's impossible to get away with
breaking plans these days like you can't
just be like hey uh so sorry i can't
make it to your self-publishing seminar
uh
uh jaw wired shut yeah that's that's
good i don't know why this is norm
mcdonald yeah yeah
yeah that'll stick yeah my job wired us
send
then your dumbass forgets the lie and
you go to a deli and tweet these [__]
hoagies are the best
hashtag [__] hoagies hashtag norm
mcdonald ruin it
social media has robbed us of some
classic lies here's one you want to
impress a girl at the bar you go up to
and you're like hey
you know ladies i'm actually an
astronaut
20 years ago girls would be like
i want to go to the moon
these days they can just be like i work
in space they check they're like really
bing says you work in a quarry
and here's an old standby lie that
nobody can use again my nana died yeah
not only can you google obituaries they
can facebook your nana
right on her wall like pete said you
died
and she tweets pete's out of the will
nana still got some fight left in her
hashtag nana
hashtag mo grandkids mo problems
[Music]